it is clear to me that it is under
threat like never before it was a
warning delivered from the depths
joining a British led scientific
expedition the Seychelles president
Danny 4 submerged 121 meters below the
Indian Ocean surface and from there in a
world-first he urged the global
community to protect our crucial marine
ecosystem from the beating blueheart of
our planet to save it yes to save it the
time to act is now but a Sky News
witness the threat to these islands is
not just deep under the water during our
deep ocean alive project we saw the
devastating effects on Aldabra atoll of
plastic pollution swept towards these
defenseless Shores well it breaks my
heart
frankly you know this is such an
incredible place and and super seen in
every way been so heavily protected
people have worked so hard to do that
and to find the world's rubbish just
drifting onto its shores is truly
mind-boggling President Ford told Sky
News his country was a victim of global
neglect and that he wants to see the
creation of more marine protected areas
the pollution the debris does not come
from my country it comes from elsewhere
we have now become a victim of marine
debris and pollution and algebra needs
to be protected and that's the problem
while the Seychelles recognizes and acts
on the issue it's pretty powerless
unless all countries in the region join
in with the fight more than two and a
half billion people live in the region's
surrounding the Indian Ocean yet it's
the least explored and most threatened
of all our oceans in the West other
Seychelles and this is where the UNESCO
World protected Aldabra atoll sits but
its position makes it vulnerable
models show most of the plastic coming
from the east coast of Africa it's in
the path of the South Equatorial current
which sweeps plastic rubbish from
throughout the Indian Ocean west towards
the algebra at all but it's being drawn
in from the Northeast too from Sri Lanka
and beyond there is a global ambition to
protect 1/3 of the world's oceans by
2030 but for that to be achieved urgent
and drastic action needs to be taken now
not just in the Seychelles
but around the world - Asha Shashi Sky
News